[Music]
trying is about a Capone who decides to
embark on Parenthood and realize that
they can't so may look into other
options I think already super adopting
yeah and they decide to go through that
process which is a lot harder than I
think they realized you're totally sure
about this god be careful with adoption
Mel from the club got a rescue dog shat
everywhere I don't know what I supposed
to do with that information
I play a social worker who's helping a
couple to try and adopt I can't get it
how often would you say you have sex I
was adopted as a young child you don't
often hear about the process and how
difficult that is and I just think it's
right for a really fantastic series so
excited the fun is gonna be watching how
these two people respond to being judged
on whether you are a good enough person
to adopt a child we should make a list
of the flaws that we want to whine out
you drink too much you need to work on
your anger
probably put it down having to grow up
and maybe realize yourself as an adult
and what that means children they're not
my children I don't think I'm ever gonna
feel like an adult we'll try to make
sense of it that's just an error of them
calmness and dependability at the end of
the day it's about what's missing and
it's about what we do to fill that hole
crazy people don't know they're crazy
and yet here we are
I think we're gonna be amazing parents